we've been waiting for weeks and it is
happening the House today is expected to
vote to send articles of Donald Trump's
impeachment to the Senate this is the
first step in starting that Senate
impeachment trial of Donald Trump which
in all likelihood is going to lead to
Donald Trump's acquittal by the
republican-controlled Senate at which
point the question will be does that
acquittal bolster Donald Trump's chances
of winning in November or does it hurt
Donald Trump's chances of winning the
house also is expected to name
impeachment managers who will prosecute
the case we may already know who those
managers are by the time you watch this
clip or listen to today's show that
decision may have already been made
according to NPR following today's vote
the house will inform the Senate it is
ready to transmit the articles across
the Capitol the Senate will respond that
it is ready to receive them and a formal
procession and reception will take place
that could happen later today the trial
again based on what we know right now
expected to start in less than a week on
Tuesday January 21st that means we will
in all likelihood have to reschedule the
david pakman show viewer chess
tournament heartbreaking to many in our
audience I know I will have more
information about that by the end of the
week Republicans are of course already
trying to limit the witnesses that will
appear Republicans are talking about
having some portions of the trial
completely behind closed doors clearing
the Senate chamber so that debate is
going to get very interesting very
quickly and there are also a ton of new
documents that should be part of the
impeachment trial that are explosive
which I will talk to you about a little
bit later this is only the third time in
history that there will be an
impeachment trial Andrew Johnson Bill
Clinton being the other two remember
that there was no impeachment trial
against Richard Nixon Nixon resigned
before being impeached after he knew he
had lost the support of the Republican
voters and of Republicans in the Senate
he would have been impeached and
convicted and chose to resign to avoid
that the difference one of the
differences between Nixon in the 70s and
Trump in 2020 is Trump has Fox News
Trump has social media Trump has one of
the most
low information electorates to put it
lightly that we've seen in a long time
so trump has and likely will not lose
the support of his sycophantic base nor
of the republican senate a very
different scenario today than what we
had under Richard Nixon so just a short
update this is happening more than
likely tomorrow once we know who will be
managing impeachment the parameters of
it the expected duration of the trial
tomorrow we'll have more of a plan for
how we'll be covering it what to expect
maybe we will start to get a sense of
which witnesses will or won't be
included what documents will or won't be
included and that is exactly what we
have to talk about next the new
documents that we are now aware of do
you feel like you just don't have enough
time to become as intellectually
well-rounded as you would like to be
that they're just not enough hours in
your week for you to read all of the
books that you want to read one of our
sponsors is called blinka stand it's an
app that lets you consume an entire
nonfiction book in 15 minutes it's only
about 8 bucks a month but you can try it
for free for a week and get 25% off a
subscription
when you go to blankest comm slash
Pakman what blinka studs is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and condense them into either text or
audio that you can read or listen to in
just 15 minutes and what you get is all
of the most important ideas and
information from the book imagine being
able to listen to an entire nonfiction
book in the amount of time it takes you
to drive or walk home from work I just
finished listening to catch and kill by
Ronan Farrow super interesting book
probably already familiar to some in my
audience and a really interesting take
at how Harvey Weinstein and his alleged
transgressions were brought to light
excellent investigative piece Blinky's
has totally transformed how I consume
information I love it of course I read a
book in its entirety when I can but
there are simply just so many books that
I want to read and would not have the
time for if it weren't for blink Asst
they have books on politics economics
philosophy science you name it you can
try it out yourself totally free for a
week and get 25% off
if you decide to subscribe just by going
to blink is comm slash Pakman I've put
the link right underneath this video
like the rest of us I bet you're going
into 2020 thinking about what you didn't
get around to in 2019 and your goals for
the new year if you want to work towards
being your best self in 2020 understand
more about the world around you and make
sure that your time is well spent then
blink astiz for you